Madison Riley dropped Jaws when she
walked on screen in grown-ups but she
disappeared soon after what happened to
her it's not unusual for celebrities to
start their own podcasts or YouTube
channels Smallville actor Michael Rosen
bomb built up a successful series called
inside of you where he invites actors
directors filmmakers and other
recognizable industry figures onto his
show similarly the office Stars Jenna
Fisher and Angela Kinsey created office
ladies where the pair revealed behind
the scenes details of the episodes and
intriguing stories about what happened
on set Madison Riley also started her
own YouTube channel but it isn't focused
on her time as an actor or model instead
it's much more personal and presented in
a vlog format while she doesn't appear
to upload videos on a regular basis nor
does she have an overwhelming amount of
content or subscribers on her Channel
she uses her time to speak directly to
the camera and audience about a variety
of topics that are important to her
Riley explores subjects such as digital
minimalism lust Awakenings and meaning
in one video she revealed why she purged
her content on X formerly known as
Twitter stating back when I lived in New
York and I acted like I knew a lot about
the world and politics I would post
articles I had to go take all those down
because I shifted and changed my
thoughts so much from when I was
extremely ignorant that I was like I
cannot have this on record as me
supporting this regardless of the
scathing reviews for grown-ups the film
performed well bringing in
$272.00 budget so it's no surprise a SQL
went into Quick development and was
leashed on the world in 2013 despite
Grown-Ups 2 being a continuation of the
story from the first film Riley didn't
reprise her role as Jasmine is that
right Riley poked fun at the fact she
wasn't in the sequel in a 2016 Instagram
post where she posed next to the film
poster and held up a middle finger with
the caption reading that one time I
wasn't in the sequel in reality any
potential appearance for Riley was
jeopardized the moment that Rob
Schneider didn't return for grown-ups 2o
in a radio interview Schneider revealed
he had to drop out of the role because
he wasn't sure if his television series
Rob would be picked up at the time since
Schneider played Jasmine's father in the
original film it's likely that all
characters related to Rob were scrapped
in favor of devoting more screen time to
Nick Schwartz and's Nick who effectively
took Schneider's spot in the cast in the
same year that Riley starred in
grown-ups she appeared in an episode of
the sitcom Pair of Kings and the high
school comedy the prankster the latter
sees Riley play cheerleader Tiffany
Fowler in a film where a teenager
creates a secret society of pranksters
who want to change the status quo of
their High School a year later Riley had
a role in another High School film prom
from there on the actor secured Parts in
lowbudget Productions such as superzero
and Fred 3 Camp Fred in fact Riley's
most high-profile gigs after grown-ups
came in the television series 2 and a
Half Men white collar and Elementary and
even in these shows she never had a
substantial part or multi-episode Arc
that gave her serious screen time
looking at Riley's filmography it's
clear she's perfectly at home in the
comedy genre from sight splitting
sitcoms to high school hilarity this is
her sweet spot in where she is truly the
most comfortable as a performer even so
there's no denying she has lacked the
right platform to show off her strengths
as a comedian as she normally appears in
supporting or minor roles that don't
allow her much screen time in 2019 Riley
posted a video of her first Venture into
standup comedy on her YouTube channel
the actor delivered a rousing six-minute
set of jokes that had the crowd in
stitches on more than one occasion and
showcased what a natural she is in front
of a live audience her topic of choice
centered on relationships especially the
dramas of dating I did make him stop to
get me a coffee because my taste in men
makes me tired Riley made fun of her own
bad experiences while indicating that
her parents multiple divorces inspired
her to never get married appearing on
the queen path podcast hosted by Sola
Riley discussed how she moved to Los
Angeles when she was just 16 years old
and didn't feel prepared for the
entertainment industry or life in
general she also revealed how she made
the decision to stop chasing her
modeling and acting career she said I
was not happy I never say I quit acting
I just just ceased pursuing it the way
that I had been for years elaborating on
what she meant Riley explained how these
industries revolved around constant
auditions and competitiveness leaving
someone's future in the hands of other
people for her she wasn't feeling value
in that anymore Riley also shared a
photo of a 2020 royalty check on her
Instagram account showing how she
received
$1.39 and captioning it love when I get
residuals from my past life considering
how she refers to it as her past life
and the pitiful amount on the check it's
likely she Harbors no plans to jump back
into the industry anytime soon after
Riley's appearance on the queen path
podcast she explained how acting and
modeling didn't give her life the
purpose she thought it would in another
personal video she posted to her
followers she added how she loved the
creative aspect of acting but she wasn't
a fan of everything else that came with
the industry she also added how she
never had the intention to become a
movie star to begin with naturally this
put her on a journey of self-discovery
to find out what is truly important to
her Riley became far more spiritual and
aware of herself now she utilizes her
platforms specifically her YouTube
channel to share her thoughts and
learnings with her followers moreover
she is a firm advocate for self-mastery
and for people being true to themselves
and attracting positive energy to their
lives